why might someone be gaining weight more  easily than another part of it could be  that just  the composition of the foods they're  eating and their inherent differences in  insulin sensitivity  insulin resistance is genetic where some  people will just  be more insulin resistant than other  people so those people that are more  insulin resistant naturally they will  have to fight harder their insulin is  going to want to be higher  all the time and so it'll be a harder  fight for them to keep it low but they  can  do it and once again the truth of the  situation is it's not their metabolic  rate  it's really this what fuel the sentiment  of what fuel are you burning  and the kind of background there is what  what is your insulin level  if insulin is high you're burning sugar  you're not burning fat  and the insulin is going to stimulate  the fat cells to grow and store energy  rather than break things down